the Star Wars saga has become a
sprawling epic expanding numerous
planets alien races and massive cosmic
battles in fact there's so much stuff
happening that sometimes it's hard to
keep it all straight and that's why
we're here to explain the entire Star
Wars story the Star Wars story begins
during a period of relative peace in the
galaxy a thousand years before the
events of the Skywalker Saga the Jedi
Order defeated the Sith order seemingly
for good while the Jedi became the
keepers of peace in the Galactic
Republic the surviving Sith secretly
began plotting to overthrow them it was
near the end of this millennium of peace
that Darth Sidious a Sith Lord who was
secretly senator sheev Palpatine of
Naboo set in motion is planned to
eradicate the Jedi and seize control of
the Republic's government as part of his
plan for galactic domination Sidious
acted as a secret advisor to the Trade
Federation ordering them to blockade and
ultimately invade Naboo
once the Trade Federation arrived on the
planet city has slipped back into his
Senator Palpatine disguise and advised
Naboo Queen Padme Amidala that the
current Chancellor of the Republic
wasn't acting in their best interests
working with his Sith apprentice Darth
Maul Sidious was able to manipulate and
manufactured tensions in the Republic
from both sides
meanwhile on a mission to protect
Amidala two Jedi Knights Master qui-gon
jinn and his apprentice obi-wan Kenobi
happened upon a young Anakin Skywalker
while repairing their ship on Tatooine
qui-gon discovered potentially
unprecedented levels of force
sensitivity in the boy after taking
Anakin with them qui-gon urged the Jedi
Council to train Anakin but the Jedi
were reluctant after qui-gon death at
the hands of Darth Maul the council
accepted Anakin as Obi Wan's new
apprentice Palpatine was elected
Chancellor at Amidala's urging granting
him a place of unprecedented power to
further his plans following the events
of the Phantom Menace tensions within
the Republic continued to rise under
Palpatine's leadership Anakin Skywalker
grew into a young Jedi Knight of
considerable force talents and finally
Darth Sidious took on a new apprentice
former Jedi Count Dooku who adopted the
sith named Darth Tyranus Dooku at
Sidious is urging created tension in the
Republic by forming the separatists as
numerous star systems threatened
succession now senator Padme Amidala
fought to keep the Republic together and
was nearly assassinated for her trouble
Obi Wan was dispatched by the Jedi
Council
find out who was behind the attempt on
her life while Anakin's stayed behind as
her bodyguard what about Senator Amidala
she will still need protecting
handle that your Padawan will Anakin
Obi Wan's investigation uncovered an
army of clones seemingly ordered for the
Republic by a dead Jedi Knight this
discovery led obi-wan to discover a
separatist gathering on the planet
Geonosis back on the Republic capital of
Khorasan Chancellor Palpatine was
granted emergency powers to use the
newly discovered clones in the fight
against the separatists launching the
Clone Wars during this time Anakin and
Padme fell in love and Anakin's internal
anger grew as he discovered the death of
his mother on Tatooine the Clone Wars
raged for three years with Dooku as the
figurehead of the separatist movement
and Palpatine is the increasingly
powerful Chancellor of the Republic the
war raged across the galaxy consuming
system after system as everyone picked
sides the Jedi Order were tasked with
joining the conflict as generals of the
Clone armies discovered during Star Wars
attack of the clones as the conflict
raged Padme remained a force in the
Senate working for unity while
mistakenly believing she could trust
Palpatine obi-wan and Anakin fought on
the frontlines and Anakin even took on a
Jedi apprentice named ahsoka tano during
this time he and Padme fell deeper in
love and they married in secret however
as the war went on Anakin's darker
tendencies grew ready for the final
stage of his plan Palpatine allowed
himself to be taken prisoner by
separatist General Grievous this
kick-started a rescue mission
leading obi-wan and Anakin to infiltrate
Grievous's ship to rescue Palpatine once
inside they found Dooku and in the
battle with the Sith Anakin killed the
separatist leader at Palpatine's past
with Palpatine rescued the Republic
pressed their advantage in the war and
Yoda and obi-wan were both sent to the
frontlines in an effort to finish the
conflict once and for all
back in chorus aunt Padme told Anakin
that she was pregnant and his dreams
became troubled by visions of his wife
dying in childbirth
Anakin grew even closer to Palpatine
especially after the Chancellor hinted
he might have knowledge that could
prevent Padme from dying during
childbirth or ever the
of Darth Plagueis the Lions the bushes
plan into its final stages Sidious
revealed himself as a Sith Lord to
Anakin while also promising him
knowledge of the dark side anakin
reported Sidious to mace Windu who
attempted to arrest the Sith Lord during
the battle Anakin chose to save the SIP
all in the hopes that Sidious could save
padme's life with mace windu dead Anakin
pledged himself to the service of Darth
Sidious in the hopes he can prevent
Padme stat city has dubbed his new
enforcer Darth Vader and then ordered
him to slaughter everybody inside the
jedi temple this began the great Jedi
purge under Sidious order 66 which
required all clone troopers to terminate
their Jedi generals on-site only a
handful of Jedi like obi-wan and Yoda
were able to fend off their attackers
meanwhile in the Senate Palpatine used
his power to declare the Jedi outlaws
and turn the Republic into the Galactic
Empire to end his self orchestrated war
Sidious sent Vader to the planet
Mustafar to kill the remaining
separatist leaders and shut down the
Clone Army then obi-wan and Yoda made
their move obi-wan went to fight Vader
on Mustafar while Yoda confronted
Sidious on Coruscant unfortunately Padme
reached Vader first and when she tried
to convince him to see the error of his
ways he nearly choked her to death by
the end of Revenge of the Sith
Sidious fought Yoda to a stalemate while
obi-wan defeated Vader and left him to
die after facing the sith obi-wan and
Yoda regrouped to a senator Bail Organa
of Alderaan clinging to life after her
husband nearly killed her Padme gave
birth to twins named Luke and Leia
before passing away leaving the children
effectively orphaned Leia was adopted by
Organa and his wife while Luke was sent
to Tatooine to live with Shmi
Skywalker's relatives the Lars family
obi-wan moved to Tatooine to keep watch
over Luke while Yoda moved to the swamps
of Dagobah
to live in solitude in the absence of
the Jedi Emperor Palpatine quickly
consolidated his vast power with Vader
by his side however even as he
celebrated his victory a small group of
leaders were already sowing the seeds of
rebellion one soon-to-be rebel leader
was han Solo a Karelian orphan living on
the streets and working for a local
crime lord when he failed to escape the
planet with his girlfriend kira unn
enlisted in the imperial navy after
three years han deserted and joined up
with an outlaw
Bekka to earn a new life for himself as
a pilot his journey led him to reunite
with Kira now a trusted lieutenant in
the crimson dawn crime syndicate
together they embarked on a journey to
steal a valuable shipment of coaxial
fuel for crimson dawn boss Dryden boss
along the way solo met his best friend
Chewbacca and obtained his trademark
ship the Millennium Falcon at the end of
the adventure Kira chose to betray and
leave Han leaving Han to work as a
smuggler for the next decade in the
years after the great Jedi purge the
Empire tried to exterminate any former
Jedi still in hiding meanwhile a small
band of resistance leaders grew more and
more organized and the Rebel Alliance
began to take root nearly two decades
after the fall of the Jedi there was a
breakthrough thanks to Galen Urso
a rebel sympathizer who had been forced
to work on the Death Star her so planted
a key flaw in the Death Star that would
allow the rebels to destroy it during an
all-out battle at Skara Jin or so and
captain Cassy and and or give their
lives to steal the Death Star plans
nearly 20 years passed between the end
of the Clone Wars in the Battle of Skara
and during that time Leia Organa and
Luke Skywalker had grown up on their
adoptive home worlds Leia now princess
of Alderaan was a key member of the
Alliance and managed to flee scare if
with the Death Star plans when she was
captured by bader she hid the plans in
r2d2 who escaped a Tatooine in a pod
with his counterpart c-3po on Tatooine
the plans fell into the hands of Luke a
farm boy with dreams of being a rebel
pilot after viewing a message from Leia
directed at obi-wan Kenobi he sought out
the old man and when the two men up
obi-wan revealed he was once a Jedi
Knight determined to get the plans to
Alderaan Luke and obi-wan booked passage
aboard Han Solo's Millennium Falcon
unfortunately Alderaan had been
obliterated courtesy of the Death Star
after our heroes found Alderaan
destroyed the Millennium Falcon was
pulled into the Death Star's tractor
beam giving Luke Han and Chewbacca the
opportunity to search for layout follow
everyone disabled the station's tractor
beam a battle broke out as Luke Han
Chewie and Leia shot their way out of
the station ball obi-wan dueled Vader
and along the waited rematch sadly the
Sith Lord killed obi-wan in front of
Luke back at the rebel base on Yavin for
the Alliance formed a plan to assault
the Death Star Luke volunteered to join
the fight while Han left with the reward
money he'd earned rescuing the princess
the last moment Han returned to help in
the battle shooting Vader out of the sky
and leaving Luke free to destroy the
Death Star with the help of the forest
Luke saved the rebel base and handed the
Empire its biggest defeat yet
three years later Vader finally located
the Alliance base on Hoth and launched a
full-scale assault prompting a rebel
evacuation Han Leia Chewie and c-3po
fled in the Falcon while Luke left with
r2d2 in his x-wing to seek Jedi training
from Yoda on Dagobah the Falcon made its
way to the gas planet to best Ben we're
so low Matt his old friend Lando
Calrissian who won willingly gave the
Falcon and her crew up debater Luke
sensing his friends were in danger went
to best been against Yoda's wishes to
save them after the bounty hunter Boba
Fett froze han Solo in carbonite to take
him to Jabba the Hutt Vader and Luke
fought in a lightsaber duel
during the fight Vader caught off Luke's
hand and revealed that he was his father
devastated and heartbroken Luke left
away from Vader rather than joined the
dark side but fortunately he was rescued
by Leia Lando and Chewie months passed
as the team developed a plot to rescue
han both lay on Lando infiltrated Jabba
the Hutt's palace wall in disguise but
Leia was captured after getting Han Solo
out of the Carbonite Luke sent c-3po and
r2d2 ahead as gifts for Jabba before
entering himself Jabba managed to
capture Luke ken tried to have both Luke
and Han executed by throwing them into a
Sarlacc pit
luckily Luke had hidden his new
lightsaber in r2d2 s body and with the
help of Han Chewie and Lando Luke
destroyed Java's bodyguards meanwhile
Leia strangled the giant worm with her
own chains after rescuing Han Luke
returned to Dagobah to find Yoda dying
after Yoda's passing Obi Wan's Force
Coast inform Luke that Leia was his
sister determined to complete his
training and restore the Jedi Luke
returned to his friends but in the midst
of the war the Empire had constructed a
second Death Star the second Death Star
was fitted with a shield around its
entire exterior generated by a satellite
dish located on the forest moon of Endor
the rebel strike included a covert
attack to destroy the shield generator
along with a full-scale fleet assault to
destroy the Death Star itself once the
shield was down Luke Han Leia and Chewie
led the Endor team while Lando Admiral
Ackbar and wedge antilles led the fleet
strike meanwhile Luke turned himself in
to Vader so he could face his father
alone on the
Death Star as their battle commenced
vader brought luke before the emperor
who attempted to convert the young Jedi
Luke resisted Palpatine's control and
fought against Vader
however after realizing he was becoming
just like his dad Luke refused to kill
Vader enraged by this the Emperor
tortured Luke with force lightning which
led Vader to pick up his master and
throw him into the station's reactor
core on Endor han and Leia destroyed the
shield generator with the help of the
native he walks and the rebel fleet
completed its mission destroying the
Death Star and effectively ending the
Galactic Empire as the new Galactic
Republic began to form with the help of
major Rebel Alliance figures like Leia
and Mon Mothma the remains of the Empire
retreated to the outer rim there they
fell under the command of a mysterious
force user named Snoke the ashes of the
Empire then gave birth to the first
order
meanwhile han and Leia had a son Ben
solo who showed the force prowess of the
Skywalker bloodline Luke made good on
his promise to rebuild the Jedi and
started a temple where Ben was a student
unfortunately Snoke began to influence
Ben and the young Jedi turned on Luke
converting some students and
slaughtering others heartbroken Luke
went into exile sensing the threat of
Snoke and the first order leia formed an
underground movement separate from the
Republic a group known as the resistance
with his military commander general
Armitage Hawke Snoke developed a massive
system killing weapon known as star
killer base meanwhile Ben solo now known
as kylo Ren sought to find Luke
Skywalker Skywalker's location was
hidden on a piece of star map obtained
by resistance pilot poe dameron and
hidden in his droid bb-8 the Droid was
ultimately found by a jakku scavenger
named Ray together with a first-order
deserter named Finn Rey stole the long
dormant Millennium Falcon and left jakku
only to run into han Solo and Chewbacca
while stopping off at the planet
takodana
Rey discovered Luke's original
lightsaber before getting kidnapped by
kylo Ren with han and chewie self Finn
was able to return Luke's map to Leia
and the resistance general Leia Organa
and the resistance launched a desperate
attack to destroy Starkiller base while
Ben Han Solo and Chewbacca tried to
rescue Rey while there han confronted
his son Ben hoping to prove to Snoke
that he truly turned to the dark side
kylo Ren murdered his father upon the
surface of the bases planets Rey took up
Luke's lightsaber and defeated
kylo Ren with their newly discovered
force powers after the battle rager need
with r2d2 and Chewbacca
to a remote island on the planet Achtung
prepared to ask Luke for guidance
following Starkiller bases destruction
the first order sent a fleet to the
resistance base on to car Poe Dameron
led a massive attack on the first order
fleet against Leia swishes losing most
of the resistances fleets in the process
while the resistance fled Rey found Luke
was unwilling to offer her any
assistance Rey was ultimately able to
convince Luke to help her but Rey began
sharing secret force connected
conversations with kylo Ren ultimately
Luke and Rae had a falling out when she
tried to convince him that kylo was
capable of redemption Rey fled the
island while forced ghost Yoda burned
down the first Jedi Temple with ghost
lightning Leia and vice-admiral foldo
staged a last-ditch effort to save the
resistance from the approaching first
order Hudson Oaks flagship Rey allowed
herself to be captured so she could try
to convert kylo who initially seemed to
be on her side rather than watch Rey die
kylo betrayed his former master and
killed Snoke
but after fighting snoke's guards
together kylo asked ray to join him in
ruling the galaxy the Jedi the rebels
let it all die right
I want you to join me ray declined and
fled to the resistance on crate after
vice-admiral whole dough flew the
resistance flagship into the first order
fleet crippling their starships new
supreme leader kylo Ren led a ground
assault on the last of the resistance on
crate there Luke based down the
first-order assault and bought the
resistance time to escape on the
Millennium Falcon
however the luke on crates was a force
projection while the real Skywalker was
still back on up to the strain of
projecting his consciousness across the
galaxy was too much and while the
resistance lived to fight on Luke became
one with the force as Rey trained with
Leia to further develop her jedi
abilities the resistance discovered that
emperor palpatine had returned
Palpatine made kylo Ren an offer kylo
could rule the galaxy as a new emperor
with the help of a long hidden fleet of
planet-killers if he agreed to kill ray
meanwhile the resistance went in search
of a Sith wayfinder which could point
the way to Palpatine and stop his fleet
before it launched as her anxiety built
during the mission Rey discovered a new
layer of darkness in her Ray's anxieties
over who she was built to a peak when
kylo Ren told her that he knew her true
heritage she was the granddaughter of
Palpatine himself after learning the
truth Rey nearly killed kylo in battle
but healed him after Leia intervened to
save her son with her dying breath
Luke's spirit urged Rey not to give up
and Rey journey 2x ago to confront
Palpatine there the revived Emperor
revealed his true plan to convert her to
become the new Empress and leader of the
sith rey refused his offer and fought
Palpatine with the help of a redeemed
kylo Ren in the end both the Emperor and
the fleet were defeated and the galaxy
was saved in the aftermath of the battle
Rey forged her own lightsaber and buried
those of her teachers in the Tatooine
desert finally she revealed that she had
taken a new name Rey Skywalker again
it's like poetry is so that they run
every stanza kind of rhymes with
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]